I think we deserve a couple's getaway
tubs thanks yeah I think you know the
perfect place in fact I do it's the
homeland of nicole kidman and russell
crowe with some of the other big stars
talking about the land down under
specifically Australia's Whitsunday
Islands they are unbelievable so I was
really very stoked when we teamed up
with tourism Australia for the adventure
of a lifetime
we've arrived in the whitsundays and it
is so incredibly beautiful but here's
the question how much can I fit in in 48
hours
74 idyllic island stretched between the
coast Queensland Australia and the Great
Barrier Reef I'm in Vic heaven first
stop checking it to cual your resort
where Taylor Swift and Chris Hemsworth
stay yeah that doors got nothing on me
next up chopper awaits we just touched
down what feels like in the middle of
the ocean but we're here on the Great
Barrier Reef and what do you do when
you're on the Great Barrier Reef you
scuba dive
a round of golf and it was time to hit
the beach my ride the 140-foot super
yacht quantum well now I know why they
call it whitehaven beach this is out of
this world in fact part of the last
parts to Caribbean moving the shot right
here day two and I'm ready to take a
walk or ride on the wild side ATVs
watersports and the wildlife park like
the rest of the whitsundays it's back in
business after cyclone Debby hit earlier
this year so that's half a mile Dean guy
this is Freddy he's a stuffed with
crested cockatoo and our second oldest
resident known about to attack he's just
like a lot more interested in stuff like
that and also sometimes that's showing
that you might want to potentially mate
with you and stuff like that oh alright
so there's a chance they could get lucky
he loves you but I mean now the parrots
I was I'm pretty good about myself I'm
not gonna lie listen I cannot say enough
about all the amazing things that
whitsunday islands have to offer I mean
it is truly unbelievable there's
something for everyone or someone like
ready well
[Music]